so your um your book The Chim Paradox is
absolutely like world famous
um I wonder if we can if I can ask you
what's the what's the Mind model that
you introduce in the book and then we'll
kind of back yeah to the 1990s what
happened is um there was an epiphany
moment and it was with a particular
patient so I won't go into the great
detail but just to say that I was able
by just asking the right questions to
talk to what I thought was a very
sensible person and then suddenly
someone who didn't seem sensible at all
and was very emotional and pretty
catastrophic in thinking so I started
looking at what do because we' now got
functional MRI scanners what does the
the research show us on this and I
started realizing that if we scan
somebody's brain and they were talking
as what I'd call a human being they were
rational they were logical so I'm going
to simplify the Neuroscience because I
realized lot of listeners are not
neuroscientists we looked at the top
part of your head the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex seem to be leading on
this and this we know is where executive
functioning takes place so in essence if
you put your oxygen supply in that part
of your brain you're going to think and
work in a certain way yeah you look for
facts logic but there's a more to it
that hit me that part of the brain works
with acceptance and start saying it is
what it is that part of the brain looks
for Solutions
as opposed to when I started moving the
patient by asking emotive questions so
things that would make them upset or
more emotional if you look at functional
scanners what will happen they'll go to
the orbit of frontal cortex just above
your eyes and now they start acting in a
very strange way they wouldn't work with
facts at all in fact they'd have great
difficulty accepting them so what they
do is go on feelings I'm not saying
they're wrong and
intuition and they'll work with those
and they won't understand facts is it's
almost like facts are not part of the
vocabulary so what you've got to I
started to see is I've got two people in
the room or two brains in the room so
then I start looking and think well how
can I understand this better and it
became two systems so then I looked and
I thought you see classic Connections in
the brain so when the orbital frontal
works it pulls on things like the
amydala
heavily um all of the brain to me is
like an orchestra so both of these
systems pull on the brain but they
select certain of the struments and the
orbit of frontal selects feelings past
experience emotion it works on trigger
points it works on behaviors so this is
behavioral therapies coming in and then
I looked at the dorsal lateral areas and
in it work with behaviors they work with
rationality and thinking so your
cognitive therapies are coming
in nice and that I thought oh this is
really good but there's more to the
brain than that so in the
center uh you you've got all this other
sort of instruments playing away they're
not the lead instruments they're not the
orchestral conductors which is what
these two other parts are they're the
thinkers but they actually contribute
heavily so I started seeing that as
being a
computer so what I'd got is the center
of the brain was a computer advising but
it does more than advise and we may get
to this uh it actually takes over so
there was a paradox that when you
imprint a belief in that computer the
two thinkers are going to be the
decision makers y have to listen to that
they can't go against it okay so for
example if you had a belief that this
building was on sound and the roof is
about to collapse then whether you think
emotionally or rationally you have to
get out of the building yeah you know so
the center of your brain it was crucial
that it seemed blank at
Birth apart from instincts and drives
it's blank belief systems start coming
in and we work them out from being
taught or experience so I started think
we can alter that and that would alter
whether you left the building or not on
your belief yeah so this all got
complicated as he's doing and I thought
this got to be made simple now I teach
at Sheffield medical school and teaching
medical students um they like things
simple and practical as I do and I'm
thinking these are doctors to be and
they're not going to be neuroscientists
they're going to be many of them GPS and
other uh careers in medicine but they
want understanding of what the patients
are thinking how they they act and how
they can work with that and so I then
had another Epiphany M I started looking
at people and thinking when they're
irrational they looked just like
chimpanzees I looked at chimpanzees and
thought they have a society which is
very similar not everything is is in
line but I started speaking to the homon
Specialists people who knew the aps but
more important the ones that were the
neuroscientists looking at the APS and
at that point I was told and I believe
them the chimpanzee and the human have
the same system in their brain when
we're reacting emotionally so but the
other rapes don't so we think in a
certain way now this has been published
20 years on in 2018 they published this
to say the other great apes the gorilla
rang a Tang bonobo they don't think like
humans and chimpanzees but we are so
close that we say this on is relative y
because we think the way they think
genetically it's not our nearest
relative the bonoy got more genes um so
I just coined the phrase said to the
students if I said you had a little
Chimp in your head and when you're in
this part of your brain that's the chimp
brain they loved it it was simple so
when you be become irrational or your
mind takes over that part of your brain
works with trigger points behaviors is
impulsive catastrophic it's a defense
system yep whereas when you move to the
dorsal lateral areas you're in human
mode now it's you but what was
intriguing is I was getting this with
patients
and then there was this moment for again
for me in Epiphany probably around just
the late '90s there was no control over
the orbit of frontal it was very fast
moving and it's a reactive system and
it's inbuilt and you're given it and
when you look at the development of the
brain it has a head start in the fetus
so it's already operating in fetal life
and it keeps going right through yep a
whole of our life uh whereas the human
part as I'm calling it didn't operate so
we come late to the party so I started
then looking at Child Development and I
found that it's obvious it became
blatant that children around two or
three start saying why and the dors
lateral areas are coming in with
reasoning before that they don't ask
it's behavioral y so for example if you
want to help a child that's distressed
distract it yeah you know and we know
that works best don't reason with it
because it can't reason so so this all
started coming together and I said I've
got to keep it simple so the students
helped me they wouldn't let me go
complex so they said right you got a
human brain which is you have you are in
control of that and that's logic
rational calm and solution finding you
got a chimp brain which you've been
given at Birth yep and that's why at the
beginning of this I said that's your
mind it's a machine you don't have a say
in it research shows that for most of us
we're on the neurotic type Spectrum our
chip system is highly strong and it's
quite reactive and impulsive but there's
a spectrum some people have very
quiescent calm chimps yeah uh and I
always say to people if you're got a
calm chimp it may seem an advantage but
actually in the long run it's a negative
because it's meant to be highly reactive
it's meant to give you warning of danger
yeah uh and that going back to your
point about um Sports people or or
anybody yeah it can be your best friend
because that thinks outside the box and
reacts quick and warns you of danger and
when are in intuitive skills research
shows are far more accurate than when we
have to try and find logic and facts
initially so working with intuition as
long as it's functioning well is
actually a massive plus so you have to
start joining forces of two thinking
brains and start working together and
again the research shows the people who
work with both the logic and the
intuition and learn how to manage them
and emotional warning signals from the
chimp system do the best hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye